bonjour merci de nous rejoindre dans le
sud huit le débat votre rendez vous
chaque mardi sur un thème de société ou
politique aujourd'hui le thème de notre
débat impôts locaux une hausse est
nécessaire les contribuables reçoivent
en ce moment elles mêmes leur avis
d'imposition
les collectivités ont tenté de limiter
les dégâts malgré les répercussions
nécessaire de la baisse des dotations
aux communes et dans les yvelines à la
taxe foncière est passé de 7 58% en 2015
à 12,58 % cette année sur les 30
communes les plus importantes des
yvelines seulement six ont ainsi voté
une hausse de la taxe d'habitation alors
ces hausses sont hélène nécessaire en
plateau avec moi pour débattre de ce
sujet harnais armelle au brier maire
adjointe en charge des finances à
montigny le bretonneux bonsoir à vous
merci nous avoir rejoints et bernard de
bain on saura vous vous étiez le maire
de saint cyr à l'école alors j'ai envie
de commencer par vous armer le brier la
taxe foncière et la taxe d'habitation
sont restées stables à montigny le
bretonneux votre commune a pris donc
justement le parti de ne pas augmenter
les impôts c'était possible à faire pour
vous oui c'était c'était encore possible
c'était encore possible cette année
parce que ça fait un moment que l'on
contraint le fonctionnement et donc on a
encore des possibilités de pouvoir
optimiser un certain nombre de choses au
niveau du fonctionnement
mais si la baisse des dotations
continuent à
arriver et si
on a des partenaires comme le
département qui lui aussi est donc je
comprends les contraintes baisse aussi
les subventions qui nous donnaient je ne
sais pas dans l'avenir je connais on
pourra faire mais pour le moment on peut
vous bernard de vinça sur l'école de
votre côté vous avez appliqué une hausse
à deux chiffres que vous avez tenté
d'alerter plusieurs fois les médias et
la population justement sur cette
problématique pouvoir là où c'est
nécessaire on ne pouvait pas faire
autrement vous défendez justement ce
point de vue
écoutez depuis 15 ans nous n'avions pas
augmenté les impôts et même deux années
de suite nous avions baissé
nous avions
une gestion qui nous a permis à la fois
de faire l'investissement et surtout 2 /
8 la dette par habitant
malheureusement
tous les efforts de gestion nous avons
fait que ce soit en terme de nombre de
fonctionnaires que sur les
investissements que nous avons ciblé ne
nous ont pas permis cette année de
continuer ce dont nous avons absolument
besoin puisque nous sommes une ville qui
grossit beaucoup à la suite
nouvelles constructions de
l'attractivité de saint si on a besoin
d'apporter du service aux habitants et
si vous jouiez sur la baisse d'emplois
de la bim si vous jouez sur l'un
diminution notre budget pour la première
fois depuis 15 on objets abc il arrive
un moment on est obligé d'augmenter les
impôts tout en restant dans la moyenne
de leurs des villes d'ile-de-france de
même nombre d'habitants on était en
dessous maintenant on est soit la
moyenne soit très légèrement en dessous
parce que montigny à la plus grosse sa
commune que du coup ils n'ont pas eu à
monter un poste n'ont peut-être pas je
ne pense pas madame bâ ou si vous
expliquer mais on a on se ressemblent
pas non on se ressemblent pas nous on
est une ville qui est encore dynamique
donc on a des désorientations ce que
j'appelle des augmentations de périmètre
c'est à dire on a des nouveaux logements
qui se construisent on a de nouvelles
entreprises qui arrivent et qui fait
qu'à partir de ce moment là on a des
recettes quand même supplémentaires qui
peuvent aller par exemple jusqu'à 400
mille euros par an actuellement en cours
sur sur montigny mais sûrement on va
devoir augmenter les impôts moment c'est
on essaye notre objectif c'est de ne pas
le cnpa de fermer si vous voulez il ya
des moments où quand même moi je rejoins
ce que ce qu'on vous dit hier il ya des
moments où de toute façon des communes
ne pourront plus parce que de toute
façon a marqué le moment où on baisse
les dotations à partir du moment où on
baisse les subventions et là il ya quand
même en particulier de la part de l'état
un manque de réflexion en fait parce que
à partir ou doublement il reporte le
problème sur sur les autres parce que
tout le monde ne peut pas avoir du
dynamisme et à partir de ce moment là
vous avez des augmentations de charges
aussi liées au personnel au oui auprès
de personnels qui sont imposées par
l'état et qu'ils sont nettement
supérieurs aux marges de manoeuvre que
l'on a au niveau de l'augmentation des
bases par exemple donc il arrive un
moment où ce transfert de l'état se
faisant sur les communes les communes ne
pourront plus donc nous on essaye on est
dans un moment on est dans un dans un
secteur où on a encore des évolutions
des évolutions possibles on essaie aussi
de garder le même service à la
population en optimisant que c'était
mais ça ça fait déjà plus de ça fait des
années qu'on le paie donc il arrive un
moment si on continue aussi à nous mais
c'est complètement nos revenus qu'on
sera bien obligé d'augmenter les impôts
mais pour moi c'est un transfert de
l'état sur les charges des communes de
toute façon sur l'autre vous serez
obligé pour ça sur mon nom sinon si la
baisse des dotations nous ne continue
pas si vous voulez je ne pense pas mais
si la bête des datations continue oui
et du cou à ces citoyens ont leur
expliquer comment à bernard devant
justement cette hausse qui comprennent
comprennent pas
on essaie de l'expliquer on a fait lever
une réunion débat je pense qu'il fera
encore l'expliquer
je regardais sur 2014 2018 la dotation
de l'état elle va diviser par deux et à
côté de ça il ya d'autres coûts on nous
a imposé comme par exemple les fonds de
péréquation que des villes bien gérées
vont donner à des villes qui sont des
paniers percés qu'on le veuille ou non
parce qu'il ya des très grosses mines la
une ça paie de lille je crois or
vous avez des des dotations
disent que nous que nous ne percevons
plus qui diminue me saint cyr était avec
deux trois quartiers qu'on appelle cucs
avec un contrat de cohésion sociale à
cause de
nombreux logements hlm de 1600 logements
hlm
pareils qu'on s'est enrichie c'est vrai
que on a eu des nouvelles constructions
donc le revenu moyen saint cyr est de 11
cents c'est énorme mon est riche
et comme on est riche on a perdu ça on a
perdu ça donc on n'a plus les animateurs
de rue il faut qu'on compense à chaque
fois qu'on nous donne on nous retire
quelque chose qu'est ce qu'on fait on
maintient le service on va supprimer 2
mâles théâtre cinéma à la piscine où on
va dire aux gens va continuer vous
apporter même service l'état nous donne
moins d'argent ils nous aident imposer
la réforme des rythmes scolaires il n'a
pas dû qu on la compense près de 600000
euros finalement le débat s'est pas à
cette hausse des impôts c'est être
plutôt est ce que on peut continuer à
donner les services malgré justement ces
baisses des dotations les gens un
minimum de services qui est absolument
obligatoire les crèches les cantines
enfin je veux dire justement dans le
contexte économique actuel où les gens
ont besoin en plus de travailler à deux
il faut bien qu'on offre les services et
quand je regarde ce qu'on offre comme un
service c'est la grosse majorité de nos
services ce qu'on appelle les avis
obligatoire si vous voulez et avait vous
avez envoyé par exemple sur des services
nous n'avons pas renier en
sur les services par contre on a essayé
via l'optimisation bien
l'informatisation via louis la
dématérialisation et c2 d'avoir moins de
personnel et donc à partir de ce moment
là de pouvoir de pouvoir supprimer des
postes c'est quelque chose que vous
refusez affaire monsieur devant on
essaie de mutualiser pour ça coûte moins
cher par exemple la piscine de saint cyr
c'est aussi celle où viennent les
scolaires de bois d'arcy de montigny et
même des nombreux puisque usant quand
ils ont des problèmes
pas de montigny par nock de de fontenay
le fleury
mais
en terme d'investissement là on ouvre
une nouvelle crèche d'ici quelques
semaines on va avoir 60 des berceaux
dans notre nouveau quartier le bâtiment
est en fin de construction qui que tout
ça il faut il faut pouvoir
ensuite mais que personnel pour le faire
tourner et une fois qu'on a le père
semaine on l'a embauché pour 30 ou 40
ans donc il y a tout ça ça fait partie
de ce que les gens ils ont besoin de ça
la cantine scolaire en france allait pas
obligatoire on pourrait effectivement
dire ben demain y'a plus de cantine
scolaire et pourtant peut pas le faire
comme disait madame comme on ferait des
parents on n'est pas en allemagne où
monsieur travail et madame était à la
cuisine et à la maison c'est terminé ça
c'est une autre époque le chef de l'état
annoncé au mois de juin et que la baisse
des dotations de l'état aux communes
seraient réduites de moitié en 2010 est
pour vous est-ce que cela peut régler
une partie de la situation sa dette a
diminué de 2,1 milliards d'euros
oui j'ai été dit là il a dit au lieu de
le faire sur un an on le fera sur sur
deux ans à ce que demandaient les
collectivités et les mairies depuis
depuis longtemps parce que je veux dire
ça permet d'essayer d'adapter et c'est
vrai que quand on a une baisse et qu'on
peut l'étaler sur plusieurs années c'est
plus je dis pas que c'est il faut le
faire mais c'est quand même plus facile
d'accord sur un budget de fonctionnement
les tractions pas d'accord si au lieu de
trouver réellement
de promesses du candidat
président qu'une fois président il n'a
pas appliqué et puis on a impliqué aux
collectivités de quel on aura demandé
plus de 11 milliards d'économies et là
rien qu'en 2016 y compris durant l'été
le président fait 7 milliards
d'économies en 4 milliards à cuba de
remises de dettes 1 milliard à la
tunisie 2 milliards à sa main pays
africains mais
et non on nous demande de continuer à
soi être obligées de répercuter soit
pour certains ils vont réduire des
services sur nos concitoyens un moment
on ne peut pas faire nous pour rendre
service aux habitants de nos villes ce
que d'état ne fait pas il faut que lié
aussi une prise en compte des efforts et
parmi les efforts le train de vie de
l'état en fait partie oui en fait
effectivement vous avez raison c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure il faut
arrêter de ponctionner les communes soit
disant pour baisser la dette de l'état
est effectivement c'est pas les communes
qui pèsent le plus dans le déficit de la
france loin de là une dernière une
dernière question j'en avais fait réagir
tous les deux avant de refermer cette
émission c'est tout le département
yvelinois qui a été impacté les reconnu
comme l'un des territoires avec la
meilleure gestion pourtant la taxe
foncière va presque doubler avec une
hausse de 66% donc il va être mis sur la
fiscalité c'est la bonne solution
finalement donc de se priver que plutôt
que de se priver de faire des
investissements pour vous deux justement
d'augmenter les impôts mais là ils
n'avaient pas la solution il n'avait pas
d'autre solution
si vous voulez quand on voit la baisse
de revenu qu'il qu'ils ont avec
l'augmentation des charges sur le revenu
minimum c'est comment le rsa je veux
dire qu'ils n'ont pas d'autre choix ils
n'ont pas d'autre choix avait il
d'ailleurs je crois qu'ils l'ont exprimé
clairement et ils ont dit que si la
situation changer et on revient
d'ailleurs à ce que nous disions tous
les deux tout à l'heure c'est les bons
élèves qui sont pénalisés c'est à dire
via les fonds de péréquation vers l'est
je veux dire c'est les bons élèves qui
sont pénalisés pour aller financer ceux
qui n'ont pas été depuis jeudi prochain
14 heures tous les présidents de
conseils départementaux
ainsi que les élus de l'île de france
sont invités à aller exprimer leur
grogne devant l'assemblée nationale
vient le rendez vous est pris ce sera
notre mot de la fin merci beaucoup à
vous de fin donc du débat qui portait ce
soir sur la nécessité ou non de la
hausse des impôts locaux pour les
communes je pense qu'on a compris
finalement voilà avec vos deux
témoignages ça s'avère finalement
nécessaire l'émission est à revoir si
notre site internet et a commenté
également à sur les réseaux sociaux je
vous souhaite une bonne soirée et à
bientôt pour un nouveau ce est 8e le
débat